alors mesdames messieurs depuis vendredi
j'ai dit devant un certain nombre de
médias que j'étais en colère et joue
avec plaisir que nous étions en colère
je vois avec plaisir que nous ne sommes
pas seuls puisque aujourd'hui vous êtes
nombreux avec nous pour dire il veut
trouver une solution une solution pleine
une solution qui soit une aile à ce
problème qui mine le nord et l'est
parisien depuis plus de dix ans le
problème de voir plus le collège de la
consommation du crack dans notre est
parisien alors bien sûr
je dis aux médias on le dit aux médias
avec karine on leur dit on fait pression
sur le gouvernement n'oublions pas une
chose c'est qu'en matière de personnes
majeures qui errent sur la voie publique
dans des conditions présentant des
troubles médicaux ou psychiatrique c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'hébergement d'urgence
trois arrêts du conseil d'état en 2005
2015 qui le réaffirme et qui disent que
c'est une compétence exclusive de l'état
et ce n'est pas le département de la
seine-saint-denis où le département de
paris qui sont compétents onglets dans
le cadre des mineurs non accompagnés au
titre de la compétence sens dit de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance donc
aujourd'hui la réponse le règlement de
ce problème est entre les mains de
l'état
c'est l'état qui doit qui est compétent
pour régler cela et au lieu de le faire
mesdames et messieurs dans le cadre
d'une approche sanitaire social médical
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur qui
s'en occupe c'est une approche
sécuritaire uniquement sécuritaire et on
nous fait croire qu'on va protéger les
banques chinoises et les patinoires et
nos amis d'aubervilliers avec ce mur
mais moi je suis venu plusieurs fois
qu'il vendredi qu'est ce que je constate
à chaque fois pas ce soir il ya une
camionnette soit police ce crs devant
ici une autre de l'autre côté et qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils gardent le mur
il garde le mur il nous protège pas ils
viennent pas là pour assurer la sécurité
dépend anti noise et dépendent chinois
c'est parce que comme ils savent que ce
mur suscite des réactions très vives de
la part de la population alors qu'on
était avec la ville de paris sur le
moins le point de présenter en conseil
de paris en conseil municipal une
convention d'entretien et de gestion
c'est la ville de pantin qui l'aurait
fait et ils nous auraient remboursé des
frais d'entretien et de gestion en
échange on était sur le point de
conclure et qu'est ce qu'on fait on
construit se veut donc voila moi j'ai
appris karine le sénateur vincent que
capo-canellas ça posait une question cet
après midi
le député stéphane peu une loterie hier
le passé à la cheville du temps on a
posé une aussi et vous avez le ministre
qui répond que demain il y aura une
réunion afin que cette installation qui
est pour quelques jours trouve des
solutions des solutions qui soient
pérennes alors je vous dis si quelqu'un
connaît l'adresse de la réunion qui y
est pour quoi faire ben qu'ils le disent
parce que le ministre ça fait deux fois
qu'il annonce cette réunion ça fait deux
fois qui dit qu' on pourrait venir car
c'est une invitation non moi non plus
monsieur la chaux vous avez reçu une
invitation non plus et ben voilà donc on
nous annonce une réunion pour régler le
problème pour trouver une solution
pérenne et humaines et humaines et
j'insiste là dessus eh ben aujourd'hui
on n'a aucune information sur ce qui
pourrait se passer demain dans paris
alors moi je vais conclure là dessus
votre beau slogan soigne les ce sont des
êtres humains en complète détresse
certes lorsqu'ils sont en situation de
manque lorsqu'ils sont en situation
de vouloir se procurer cette drogue du
terrible qui tue cette drogue qui
détruit qui vous transforme en pantin
désarticulé et ben vous avez des hommes
et des femmes qui sont dépendantes et
tout ça pour 10 euros un sac août la
dose c'est pour ça que des fois ils ont
des démarches par rapport à cela eh bien
il faut soigner ses jeux il faut leur
proposer un parcours thérapeutique
médicale sociale il paraît des enquêtes
ont été faits que 60 à 70 % d'entre eux
sont prêts à rentrer dans un tel
parcours et la deuxième chose autre beau
slogan soigner les mais aussi protéger
nous le quartier des quatre chemins a
besoin que ça soit rapporte un ouvrier
de sérénité et de calme nous avons
beaucoup de problèmes nous travaillons à
les surmonter nous commencions à voir
quelques petits signes positifs et
aujourd'hui avec cette situation on a
bien peur avec karine franclet que
beaucoup de nos efforts se retrouvent
ruinés et que nous retournions à la case
départ alors monsieur le ministre
monsieur le premier ministre que nous
avons saisi le premier ministre
répondait nous répondez-nous
positivement positivement pour trouver
une solution médicale sociale et
sanitaire à cette situation qui est
aujourd'hui est inarrêtable notre agglo
colère et nous voulons une solution pour
régler le problème merci
bonjour et bienvenue à tous vous qui
nous rejoignent et dans ce direct et les
18h23 nous sommes en direct sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre page youtube
figaro live pour suivre en direct et
commenté un rassemblement de riverains à
pantin dont vous venez de voir les
images avec la déclaration du du maire
de pantin doit pas de notamment alors
ces manifestants protestent contre
l'installation des taupes des
toxicomanes addict au crack à cet
endroit dans leur quartier près du
quartier des quatre chemins donc à
l'orée des villes de banlieue de pantin
et aubervilliers et porte porte de la
villette côté côté paris alors pour
commenter ces images et poursuivre donc
cette manifestation je suis dans le
studio du figaro avec luc antoine lenoir
bonjour donc vous êtes journaliste au
figaro et notamment en charge des faits
divers vous avez couvert les évacuations
de ces toxicomanes du xviiie et du 19e
arrondissement notamment et puis pour
vous faire vivre la manifestation en
direct sur place donc je nous thibault
ysore notre reporter
thibault est ce que vous nous entendez
ce que vous nous voyez je vois que vous
filmez donc vous avez le mur justement
ce fameux mur de pantin juste en face
que vous voyez sur ces images de notre
reporter thibault ysore est ce que est
ce qu'il ya du monde
merci de
nous rejoindre vous m'entendez
tout à fait alors vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi ce mur sur lequel on va
avoir l'occasion de revenir lors de ce
live qui est bien symbolise un petit peu
la colère de ses riverains et de ses
élus qui se sont rassemblés vous avez pu
les entendre juste avant mais également
et bien mais bien ces personnes
rassemblées que je vais vous montrer
tout de suite ici dans le quartier des
quatre chemins à pantin qui est donc et
bien le centre un petit peu des zones
concernées par cette ce déplacement de
personnes toxicomanes et qui donc est
bien ici et ici pour se mobiliser et
exprimé sa colère il a vite cette cette
situation avec et bien c'est panneaux
que vous pouvez voir ces personnes qui
sont venues se mobiliser contre se
déplacent
vous suivre on va retourner sur vos
images tout de suite mais d'abord pour
tous ceux qui nous regardent et qui
n'ont pas suivi le dossier forcément
luc-antoine est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler brièvement la chronologie la
chronologie de cette affaire pourquoi il
arrive aujourd'hui pour de la ville est
alors le crack à paris c'est une
histoire qui ne date pas d'hier ça fait
plusieurs en fait le crack à paris si on
veut être précis est arrivé à la fin des
années 80 début des années 90 dans paris
et puis ça a était sporadique qui est
plusieurs quartiers qu'on était un petit
peu touchés mais là depuis quelques
années mais une concentration avec
l'arrivée notamment de dealers
sénégalais qui ont pignon sur rue dans
les quartiers du xviiie et du 19e
arrondissement de paris il ya une
concentration autour du quartier
stalingrad d'abord qui a mené qui a
amené beaucoup de problèmes pour les
riverains puisque effectivement quand
ces gens se sont pris 7 ce petit caillou
à 5 ou 10 euros ils deviennent
extrêmement dangereux il se met en
danger ils mettent tous les gens en
danger donc beaucoup d'agressions
d'enfants de mères etc qui poussaient
leur qui avaient des poussettes
il ya une petite stratégie des pouvoirs
publics consistant à les faire un petit
peu se décaler vers les jardins d'eole
ce sont ces ce sont ces un parc en fête
qui longe des rails dans le nord de
paris qui est qu' à quelques centaines
de mètres ils sont restés là pendant
plusieurs mois pour un peu plus d'une
année en fait est là exactement pareil
le quine le parc a été à peu près
entièrement envahie et puis les
riverains subissent et ses nuisances en
juin dernier il ya eu une espèce de un
scénario un petit peu un affrontement
entre la préfecture de police et la
mairie de paris avec la mairie de paris
qui a tergiversé un petit peu qu'ils ne
savaient pas trop quoi faire de ces gens
puisque ça fait des années de toute
façon qu'on ne sait pas quoi en faire et
là de la préfecture de police qui
voulait les amener dans un lieu donc
porte de la villette qui est un petit
peu plus éloigné des habitations c'est à
dire c'est un grand rond point sous le
périphérique tout ce qu'il ya de plus
voilà enfin c'est une grande
architecture urbaine urbaine mais les
habitations soient un petit peu en recul
à l'époque anne hidalgo n'avait pas
voulu de cette solution elle a préféré
fermer les jardins d'eole la nuit aux
toxicomanes dont qui se regroupent
c'était un petit peu c'était presque
pire pour certains du quartier puisqu'il
se regroupaient et ensuite la il ya
quelques jours la préfecture de police a
de façon unique une ligne latérale
choisi d'emmener les toxicomanes des
jardins d'eole vers la place de la porte
de la villette où il y en avait déjà
quelques-uns mais où c'est en maintenant
désormais regroupées et un petit peu
mieux contrôlé ou surveillé au moins
alors vous qui nous rejoignent et dans
le chat je vais vous je vais vous saluer
son de l'âme johan d'aida sur le chat du
figaro.fr merci d'être avec nous en
direct posé nous vos questions à notre
reporter sur place thibault isolé ou à
luc antoine lenoir spécialiste de ces
questions ici journaliste fait divers au
figaro yoann d'aida qui s'est pas
vraiment une question mais qui nous fait
part de sa remarque sur lefigaro.fr et
qui nous dit je plains les riverains et
les commerçants obligé de surveiller des
drogués justement on va on va retourner
sur sur le terrain tout de suite
retrouvé thibault pour voir s'il a pu
rencontrer ces riverains excédés qui
sont dans cette manif
je me propose de le faire en direct dans
les prochaines minutes là vous le voyez
on a eu des déclarations publiques des
élus notamment de la maire
d'aubervilliers et du maire de pantin on
a pu
à voir ces déclarations officielles vous
voyez toute cette foule qui se
rassemblent à s'organiser en entité
pourrait bien être un peu plus
impactante dans ses messages qu'on
puisse mieux voir les messages sur les
banderoles et donc commencé à spéculer
sur qui coopèrent avec le sujet mobilise
pas mal puisque beaucoup de journalistes
à mes côtés des confrères de nombreux
médias différents temps de la presse
nationale que la presse régionale qui
sont ici pour suivre donc cette
banderole et ce message impactant est
assez fort de la part des élus ici que
vous vous lassez image
continue a commenté les images donc de
thibaut ysore luc-antoine on a vu tout à
l'heure donc donc ce mur notamment il ya
un graff sur ce mur qui s'appelle enfin
il est écrit mur de la honte pourquoi
pourquoi ce mur c'est le mur de la
discorde qu'est ce qui se passe avec
seigneur en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que donc autour de ce rond-point
non je parle dans le nord de paris porte
de la villette il et les toxicomanes ont
été massés sur un espèce de terre plein
qui longe le périphérique et c'est vrai
que juste à droite de ce terre-plein
quand vous venez de venait de paris vous
avez un tunnel qui passait sous
boulevard périphérique et qui a mené
directement à pantin donc pour les
habitants de pantin notamment qui
travaille à paris ça faisait ça empêcher
un très long détour et surtout de passer
par des voies immense en fait réservé
aux voitures donc il ya beaucoup de
piétonniers ou de jean vélo qui
utilisaient tous les jours ce ce tunnel
dans les deux sens et c'est
depuis que les toxicomanes sont là
vraiment nombre qui sont difficiles
enfin qui sont à peine contrôlable par
là par la police il ya évidemment un
problème de sécurité qui se crée avec ce
tunnel puisque c'est assez un lieu
restreint qui est difficilement
contrôlable si les gens commencent à
ceux à ceci les toxicomanes commence à
s'y masser pour les piétons les
riverains ça va devenir très très
difficile donc effectivement la
préfecture a mis en avant cet impératif
de sécurité a préféré muret le tunnel
entièrement alors effectivement ça
oblige les c'est vraiment pour la
sécurité dépend tinois qu'ils ont érigé
ce pur c'est sur les arguments de la
préfecture de police et la préfecture de
police qui assume elle dit que c'était
une indispensable protection des
habitants de pantin c'est préfet
lui-même qu'il a dit est donc en fait
c'est effectivement dommageable pour les
habitants de pantin puisque maintenant
ils prennent un chemin un peu différent
un peu rallongé pour arriver à paris où
l' inverse les parisiens pour arriver à
pantin mais c'est vrai que c'est pas le
chemin en tant que tel qui est bouché
c'est vraiment cet espace clos sous les
4 ou 6 voies du périphérique je sais pas
bien qui constitue en fait un danger
parce qu'ils sont dans le noir ils vont
ici des riverains commencent à y aller
très tard et c'est à ça peut devenir
extrêmement dangereux donc une présence
policière 24 heures sur 24 est pas
possible pour ce petit espace ils ont
choisi de muret
alors on va regarder les images de
thibaut ysore en direct nous sommes donc
toujours dans le cortège des
manifestants du rassemblement donc du
collectif anti crack 93 qui protestent
donc contre la délocalisation qui s'est
pas vraiment le terme le délogement on
va dire des créateurs du 18ème et 19ème
arrondissement de paris
dans aux portes on va dire de leur ville
aux portes de leur vie la porte
d'aubervilliers
on a vu plusieurs plusieurs pancartes ni
craquelant denis
g ni craquelant denis j'ai pas la fin
merci merci thibault ni craquelant denis
crématorium voilà sur sur la banderole
des images de thibaut ysore
est ce qu'on peut faire un point luc
antoine sur la consommation de deux
cracks
à paris ou en ile-de-france est ce qu'on
a des chiffres est ce qu'elle est en
augmentation en progression ces
dernières années alors elle et les
chiffres sont assez difficiles vont
céder estimations préfectoral policières
etc on estime qu'il ya plus de dix mille
consommateurs de crack régulier dans
paris et est parmi ceux là il ya cette
population vague fin vagabonde c'est à
dire un peu en déshérence isolées
socialement qu'on appelle donc ses
cracker du nord de paris qui représente
entre selon les estimations de 700 à
bientôt 2000 personnes ça par contre
c'est vrai que c'est un chiffre en
augmentation et de toute façon ça se
voit depuis la rue ce sont maintenant
des espèces dehors de gens qui parfois
sont dans des états vraiment c'est
difficilement descriptible mais c'est
voilà ils sont ils sont ils sont ils
tiennent à peine debout et ils sont
agressifs et face à ça c'est vrai que la
mairie de paris les pouvoirs publics ne
savent pas très bien comment nous
prendre le problème d'autant plus qu'ils
sont divisés sur la réponse sanitaire
donc c'est pour ça que là on voit ses
habitants qui disent soigner et protéger
nous c'est à dire que la préfecture de
police face ce sont de voir en nous
protégeant et peut-être que la mairie où
l'état façon de voir en faisant le
social qui est qui est nécessaire sur
cette question
alors je salue leur où tu es soudan dans
le chat du figaro.fr merci d'être avec
nous un habitué un habitué de nos
directs on retrouvera tout de suite plus
tard
thibault ysore qui va forcément aller à
la rencontre de ses riverains on voit
qu'ils sont accompagnés en tout cas sûr
sur ces images de nombreux élus avec
leur échappe on a entendu en tout début
de direct donc le maire de pantin et il
succéder à la maire d'aubervilliers qui
sont les deux communes on va dire
limitrophes qui sont les plus touchés on
va dire par par ceux des logements où
tout cas cette installation des
toxicomanes dans à la porte de la
villette sont de l'âme qui continuent de
commenter nous faire part de son avis
sur le chat du figaro.fr et je le
remercie et qui nous dit ce n'est pas
qu'une histoire de mur c'est aussi une
histoire de symboles murray ça rappelle
forcément berlin ça rappelle également
trump est ce que c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il ya une grande mobilisation
aujourd'hui le symbole est fort bien sûr
oui oui une symbolique c'est vrai que
c'est assez c'est là c'est le symbole
d'une séparation
bon géographique certaine après il faut
relativiser c'est vrai que le symbole
politique l'a utilisé par les gens qui
s'opposent à surtout aussi à la
délocalisation des crackers dans leur
quartier je pense que c'est assez fair
play qui utilise ce symbole et qui le
dénoncent en revanche bon il ya il ya un
détour de quelques centaines de mètres
qui évidemment et qui c'est vrai est pas
très pratique voire un peu risqué
puisque on passe à côté des voitures
mais ça reste un tunnel qui est bouché
dans les deux sens et qui est en
revanche sous le périphérique il ya
quand même beaucoup d'axés ça se limite
à une je pense une comparaison un peu
historique et politique là dessus et est
ce que c'est pour ça peut-être qu'il y à
des élus qui prennent part à cette
manifestation est aussi à l'époque des
jardins d'eole il y avait énormément de
manifestation de riverains aussi j'ai
pas le souvenir qu'il y ait beaucoup
d'élus en tout cas il y avait moins
d'élus sur les premiers plans des
manifestations comme on le voit là les
images en fait si vous voulez lors des
manifestations contre les cracks heures
au jardin d'eole le problème c'est que
les élus étaient dans le viseur des
manifestants c'était la mairie de paris
à qui on disait mais prenez ce problème
en main c'était aussi la préfecture de
police ce qui est acquis on disait
faites quelque chose donc c'est pas les
élus mais bon quand même les pouvoirs
publics alors que là les élus
d'aubervilliers de pantin sont pris au
dépourvu quand il l'a dit bien il a bien
dit le maire il ya quelques instants il
a dit on nous a absolument pas concertés
nous on s'apprêtait à faire un entretien
du tunnel en concertation avec la mairie
de paris fin bref tous leurs plans sont
complètement rebattu et puis
effectivement il ya ce côté la mairie de
paris la préfecture de police décide on
est les victimes et puis effectivement
encore une fois il utilise ce symbole du
mur c'est normal c'est parce que eux
veulent maintenir là comment dire le le
bon la bonne accessibilité des pentes
ynwa à la ville de paris aux endroits où
il ya du boulot et c'est donc ils
défendent leurs habitants c'est normal
on va retrouver thibault ysore tout de
suite sur place on a vu que vous aviez
un petit peu avant c'est ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer où se dirige le
cortège
est l'origine de votre présence ici
aujourd'hui
oui
vous êtes priés l'équipe à la ville de
pantin c'était important pour nous comme
pour vous des demi
finales sera santé
quartier des quatre chemins
vous savez les difficultés plus du
quartier
et tout ce qu'on fait pour améliorer la
vie des habitants du quartier des quatre
chemins
c'est en dollars
pour vous en tant que justement
conseiller municipal et finalement que
représentant local qui connaissait la
vie la vie et du quartier et de la ville
de lhassa qu'est ce que ça signifie
cette situation
cette situation nous fait reculer parce
que
c'est tout ce travail qu'on fait
on voir améliorer la vie & véranda
claire des habitants du quartier
son
si tu sais
sage pour nous c'est pas acceptable
au-delà du fait
chaque habitant de la ville sa
position à votre niveau
santé écoutez en tout cas aujourd'hui
par exemple votre mobilisation par les
autres ils espèrent respect que nos
autorités
sont une chance
sache pas déplacé je pense qu'en
peinture au quesnoy
et en tant que haut dirigeant une
responsabilité qu'il prend soin d'eux
désinfectant en fonction de la
population
les arrêtés qui
qui dit clairement que sa beauté de
l'état que de ce côté des gens qui sont
dans cette situation
à la fin je refusais
c'est tout
laverty
voilà donc vous voyez brune paris
justement la dôle cette mobilisation des
élus locaux des différentes villes
concernées par ce déplacement personnes
toxicomanes et vous voyez bien même au
niveau locales et des élus qui font un
peu dans le retrait ou en tout cas moins
dans la dans la discussion publique on a
beaucoup de colère c'est dégueulasse
avec cet homme
te ment elle est élue
thibault très prochainement
effectivement on voit sur les images
donc de thibaut ysore et qu'il y a qu il
ya beaucoup de monde est-ce qu'on a
l'impression quand même qu'il déplace le
problème à chaque fois qu'ils vont
déplacer on va dire c'est qu'en deux
toxicomanes les riverains vont
l'accueillir du du même accueil aura
toujours ce genre de problème sur des
situations alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire en fait au lieu de les déplacer
quelle est la solution là le problème
c'est qu'effectivement il ya une
paralysie des pouvoirs publics qui vient
de
la division sur les réponses à apporter
vous avez la mairie de paris qui plaide
pour le soin le soin le soin installé
l'accueil c'est à dire que en gros
on ne commet dire on ne va pas
désintoxiquer quelqu'un contre son avis
donc il faut d'abord lui permettre de le
faire dans des conditions sanitaires
satisfaisantes
ensuite peut-être de commencer à engager
un dialogue avant éventuellement de
d'envisager une une comment dire une
thérapie qui permettent de le sevrer etc
donc c'est un espèce de processus social
qui passe au début par des centres
d'accueil ils veulent multiplier les
centres d'accueil à paris et
éventuellement les salles de
consommation à moindre risque donc les
salles de shoot et en revanche d'autres
d'autres administrations comme surtout
la la région ile-de-france valérie
pécresse à la région ile de france dit
non pas du tout il faut faire descendre
sanitaires dans lesquelles ces gens là
après avoir reçu des autorités
judiciaires des injonctions de soins
puisque c'est un dispositif qui existe
dans le droit français soient pris en
charge et désintoxiquer pas de force
mais en tout cas soit mis dans des
hôpitaux spéciaux et il faut créer
plutôt un centre sanitaire dédié à sa au
sevrage directement donc ces deux
théories qui s'affrontent et en
attendant qu'elle fonctionne alors
laquelle fonctionne
c'est très compliqué en tout cas le
l'état prend plutôt le parti de là des
salles de shoot olivier ferrand a
annoncé qu'il ouvrirait 2 par an en
france
il y en a pour l'instant une à
strasbourg et une à paris il faut aller
voir les riverains pour leur demander si
ça marche il faut leur certains enfin
ils vous disent que effectivement la
consommation sur la voie publique baisse
puisque bon les les toxicos vont le
faire dans un endroit un petit peu un
petit peu encadré mais en revanche le
comportement de quelqu'un complètement
si vous les abrutis par le crack ils
changent pas une fois qu'ils sont faits
l'injection qu'ils ont à gérer la drogue
ils ressortent et puis peut y avoir des
agressions des voiles à des nuisances
donc les riverains sont quand même un
petit peu déboussolés la preuve c'est
qu'ils voulaient installer une salle de
shoot à côté d'une école dans le 20e
arrondissement de la ville a récemment
la mairie de paris a dû refuser parce
que tout le monde s'est dit mais enfin
faut pas prendre les gens pour des
idiots ils vont ça va peser des gros
problèmes de sécurité notamment avec des
enfants donc c'est un peu délicat comme
question la mairie de paris fait
résolument ce choix là sur le terrain
effectivement quand on a écouté une
salle de shoot c'est pas la même chose
alors johan d'aida sur le chat du
figaro.fr nous nous nous pose une
question alors peut-être que vous aurez
la réponse si vous l'avez pas vous
pouvez dire vous n'avez pas lui n'est
pas de questions pièges la dépendance au
crack est très rapide question qui
approvisionne les toxicomanes alors
c'est ce sont des filières en les cracks
cds dérivés de médicaments il ya aussi
plein de choses comme ça mais donc pour
la filière du crack en particulier il ya
beaucoup de dealer qui viennent
notamment de communautés sénégalaises ou
du golfe de guinée ça s'appelle des mots
doux c'est un terme africains qui veut
en fait qui désigne ceux qui disent des
mots doux à ceux qui a ce don de a qui
veulent vendre ces substances walla est
donc ces dealers mode où effectivement
là aussi certaines personnes critiquent
beaucoup puisqu'ils disent mais rien
n'est fait il ya des obligations de
quitter le territoire qui sont pas
appliquées il n'y a pas deux sur la
filière de l'approvisionnement du détail
de la distribution de ces drogues il ya
évidemment une politique à mener alors
la préfecture de police met en place des
choses mais effectivement elle est
tributaire aussi des volontés du maire
de l'état
on va regarder on va suivre on va
laisser un petit peu vivre les images de
thibaut ysore qui nous fait des gros
plans sur surtout de ses pancartes de
manifestants on va laisser vivre les
images
un compte a d'abord souligné
l'excellence des relations entre carrick
franklin et moi même sur ce dossier
sur ce dossier
parce que
quand il s'agit de l'intérêt supérieur
dans deux communes
de mer lorsqu'on nerfs on doit être
capable de se rassembler de se mobiliser
et avec karine français c'est ce que
nous faisons depuis vendredi tous les
deux chacun dans leur ville ou lorsque
nous prenons des initiatives communes
comme ça encore aujourd'hui la deuxième
chose c'est que je voudrais remercier
publiquement parce que je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de le faire les 37 élus de
seine-saint-denis qui nous ont apporté
leur soutien
[Applaudissements]
qui aujourd'hui sont à nos côtés et qui
veulent aujourd'hui que les services
soient défendus et qu'elle assène sony
soit respectée parce qu'il s'agit des
plus ni moins que de ça alors merci à
eux il peut rester là le mali a sorti
une réunion importante
nous attendons avec beaucoup
de prudence karine et moi les suites de
cette réunion ce qui pourrait y avoir
dans cette réunion et tu pousses mais en
tout état de cause on restera très
attentif et si d'honneur les choses
n'avancent pas et dans ce qu'il possède
9 lundi prochain je serai à vos côtés
merci
[Applaudissements]
je présente alors monsieur bastien
lâcher
oui très très rapidement parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dites si nous
sommes tous rassemblés ici
les citoyens les élus mobilisés c'est
que me dire que nous n'avons nous pas
nous ne voulons pas de cette situation
qui
[Musique]
méprise les habitants de 7,5 minutes
avant la ministre de l'intérieur de la
mer du préfet hippiques qui quadrillent
rien à côté de ce soir c'est simplement
l'existence des habitants la section nie
l'existence de leurs problèmes ni
l'existence de la volonté de vivre
tranquillement de vivre sereinement ne
vouloir vivre simplement voilà donc là
c'est ce que nous disons aujourd'hui il
fait apporter une solution sanitaires le
problème des toxicomanes il faut pouvoir
les héberger il n'est pas possible que
dans vingt sixième puissance du monde il
y est fait sur tel de places dans les
hôpitaux dans des centres spécialisés
pour régler ses problèmes d'addiction
c'est inconcevable
également
placé force et d'insécurité qu'elle en
fuite allaient prendre leur médecin
j'allais travailler sans avoir à faire
des détours par ce qu'on construit un
mur de la note mais mieux scandaleux
nous ne sommes pas
en allemagne de l'est nous aiment pas au
mexique il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
construit un mur entre paris
mais vous connaissez bloc voilà pourquoi
si demain lors de cette fameuse oignons
pas laquelle on est en tout cas une
invitation je crois que les deux mais
trois heures ici n'ont toujours pas reçu
d'invitation c'est quand même un comble
si cette réunion d'avoir deux pas de
solution bien évidemment que mercredi
prochain tout cela et je suis ravi
on va laisser thibault sylla quelqu'un
j
je suis je pourrais vous demandez
pourquoi vous êtes ici aujourd'hui je
sais pas qui m'a choqué
bush a déjà eu un gros problème vu que
les bandas du club
l'humeur est
des panthères supporte les frais de
compte on essaie de régler les problèmes
et maintenant avec darmanin dépasse les
problèmes simples
les murs de la honte manger à mes débuts
devant du dernier mois
mais jamais la soupe et à les dépasser
pour un blog est pas régler
les problèmes
par contre que ces gens là il faut les
soigner pour baliser à l'abandon parce
que c'est bon c'est comme ça va être
entre les banques d'un dealer et après
on va retomber de jazz comme un martyr
dgo cette approbation ne sera due aux
chasseurs bénévoles
pour trouver une bonne solution parce
que contact [ __ ] et affrontant chacun
tente un duvet très très très belle
ville rose où on est tous internet en
arrière de l'êta main et lamby de gâcher
la côte rentrée ne s'est pas aujourd'hui
d'autre part voilà s'il vaudra beaucoup
d'élus se soit on voit bien leur dire
c'est qu'ils sont présentés qu'est ce
que ça vous fait de votre cérémonie
comme après ce match est content parce
que et pourtant c'est qu'on est parti
plus d'abord par le but de rejoindre par
des bornes aucune d'un beau cadeau pour
moi j'étais 2
de plus belle la vie est belle la vie
fait balader ou d'analystes aussi
champagne les autres
déjà quand après
je crois en fait trop tard maintenant
c'est vrai on a envie de garder le
contact
mais si le franc
conseil merci
je comprends sur un an
vous avez vu est vraiment entendu cette
déclaration d'amour de 7,2 cette
habitante à la ville de pantin elle
vient donc voilà je vous écris mais cela
c'est aussi ça la raison que la raison
de la présence auprès de ces personnes
et ce soir c'est pour justement et bien
leur ville avec les biens six
représentants ces élus mais également
vos fruits d'habitants qui est bien
veulent que le mode de vie dans leur
bible ne soit pas avec un perturbé par
la venue de population vous reviendrez
pas aimé ce qu'expliquait personnes
avaient donc
ce qui ne ferait que déplacer le
problème pour voilà explique un petit
peu en conclusion les témoignages de cet
habitant
ça fait écho donc un commentaire sur le
chat du figaro.fr je vous remercie de
nous su d'ailleurs posé nous vos
questions si vous en avez nous y
répondrons en direct sont de l'âme qui
nous suit depuis le début et qui est qui
abonde dans le sens de ce que vient de
dire thibault ils auraient déplacé des
dépendants égale déplacer le problème et
qui soumet donc une question que je vais
poser à luc antoine qui nous demandent à
propos des salles des shoots des salles
de shoot à paris est ce qu'on a un bilan
sur celles qui existent déjà
il ya des bilans alors il ya des bilans
qui sont faits par la communauté de kiel
l'établissement qui a une délégation de
service public pour s'occuper de ces
salles de shoot sur les cookies sont
engagés etc il ya surtout en fait la
vraie influence que peut avoir la salle
de shoot c'est effectivement une baisse
relative dans le quartier des scènes de
consommation de rue comme on disait
c'est à dire que effectivement au a -
enfin ce n'est plus juste a dit m du
dealer que ils prennent la la la
substance mais voilà ils font l'effort
d'aller dans un endroit comme ça où ils
sont un petit peu encadré en revanche
iliad et il ya beaucoup de billets qui
empêche de faire un bilan chiffré très
précis là-dessus il ya un périmètre de
tolérance quand même de la police qui ne
évident de s'intéresser à quelqu'un qui
a un comportement un peu pratique si il
y à quelques mètres de la salle de shoot
puisque bon là on admet que la personne
puisse être sous substances puisque
légalement et enfin c'est pas c'est pas
d'injecter légalement mais elle a pris
dans des conditions
d'encadrement par par les pouvoirs
publics mais surtout le problème c'est
que on n'a pas deux il n'y a aucune il
ya aucun effet sur le sevrage des gens
sur la désintoxication c'est quelque
chose qui en cas de la consommation si
la consommation va écouter les images
j'ai à une altercation indirectes
au caire
et qu'est ce qu'elle a dit son cabinet
voilà la preuve sont plus des rumeurs là
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
allée voir darmana quand même il encourt
donc on essaye de s'unir on nous a caché
allez voir
ces personnes
les personnes c'est-à-dire les merci aux
élus doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités
je pensais quand il ensuite on va tuer
que ce projet et qui ont l'air y est
hélas on ne les suis et moi c'est suffit
pas d'écrire on agit c'est parce qu'une
fois élue pour représenter les amigos
ces jeunes à le bouger ces galonnés
j'espère alors bougez habré que la
décision est prise c'est trop tard
monsieur j'ai tendance parce que vous
avez entendu décision avait été tendue
je me suis dit
bush l'étude vous avez entendu le
premier ministre l'enfer cage et les
noirs philippe quand il est venu au
rwanda dit de notre département il a 10
de la rue mais dans la galerie lors
paris-tours famille est inquiète
encore moi qui vais la voir
pendant samedi quand je l'écrasé
j'appelle un qui n'est pas un débat mais
tout le monde était aux anges et l'ama
ne plus faire pas du tout pas du tout
les
we
salute change
ce que j'ai à dire c'est que monsieur
bastien lachaud qui est des bus député
d'aubervilliers pantin a prévenu il a
fait un courrier au mois de juillet que
ce projet était dans les cures d'accord
lors du conseil municipal au mois de
juillet dernier si mes souvenirs sont
bons notre mère madame franck les
addictions etc ce ne sont que des
rumeurs moi j'estime qu'en député vous
préviens vous devez prendre vos
précautions et pas attendre le 29
septembre 2021 pour se réveiller quand
la chose est faite qu'est ce qui vous
fait pas du coup ce soir devoir de ses
élus représentés ici est ce que ça veut
dire quelque chose corporeau se sont
certes rien du tout pour moi rien du
tout moi j'estime qu'il faut sévir le
mal avant qu'il soit fait d'accord on
prend ses précautions on n'attend pas
que des personnes malades ce sont des
personnes malades il faut les
accompagner il faut les soigner et ne
pas les enfermer déjà c'est honteux de
les enfermer c'est inadmissible ce sont
des êtres humains ça peut être moins ça
peut être votre heure votre enfant ça
peut être mon enfant on n'attend pas que
ça soit fait maintenant mais le fait
qu'on dise un an nous avons été sidérés
c'est un simulacre tout cela ces
personnes auront été pris depuis le mois
de juillet rumeur sim sont pas des
rumeurs nous avons été mis devant le
fait accompli
j'entends des déclarations de l'ue mais
je veux aussi qu'un certain ras-le-bol
par mina populaire et un rebelle parce
que on vous fixe et mathis mme le
département de la seine saint denis je
ne sais pas si vous vous en souvenez
lorsque l'ancien premier ministre
edouard khoury et vieux au mois de
novembre 2009 il a traité le département
de la seine saint denis le 9-3 pendant
la tendance à le dire comme un
département hors norme en apportant des
solutions qui sont complètement ridicule
ridicule on aimerait nous habitons ces
canaux dionysien qu'on nous prête à
égalité comme les hôtels com comme les
yvelines tout simplement alors on
ramasse toute la misère du monde et on
continue à la ramasse et il faut pas
oublier qu'on est plus de un million six
cent vingt-quatre mille habitants et
quand on voit les moyens donnés à nos
jeunes les moyens sanitaires et autres
ils sont totalement ridicules alors
maintenant stop ça suffit
[Musique]
voilà vous avez entendu cdsn en fait
pendant la
précédente interview que je faisais tout
à l'heure j'entendais des cris un petit
peu dans l'autre côté des altercations
et c'est en fait ce ras-le-bol qu'on
vient d'entendre cette de cette
habitante avec beaucoup de jeunes
également qu'ils sont montés au créneau
certains qui appelait à ce qu'on reste
plutôt passer par les les riverains et
non pas les élus et justement sera pour
ce ras-le-bol vous avez finalement de la
situation de la gestion de leur ville
qui finalement aujourd'hui et bien être
un peu tard face à face et une gestion
qui est compliqué désormais une fois que
maintenant la population est déplacé
mais vous l'avez vu en tout cas ce sera
le bol à assez fort d'essayer de
rapprocher de vous faire vivre un petit
peu les nouvelles déclarations qui sont
faites et justement bien de sentir un
petit peu le vrai coup j'ai envie de
dire au delà des déclarations de naples
entendre ici à pantin
merci thébaux on vous retrouve dans dans
quelques quelques minutes luc antoine gg
plusieurs questions on a déjà évoqué
c'est un petit peu avant mais sur le
chat de youtube il ya pas mal de gens
qui sont arrivés notamment no fake et
commodore qui débattent nos fai qui dit
c'est sûr que déplacer un problème n'est
pas le résoudre je suis tout à fait
d'accord et qui pose du coup une
question toute simple voire naïve alors
quelle est la solution à ce que vous
avez des idées pour résoudre du coup le
problème enfin endiguer donc
ce problème de crack dans le nord-est de
paris bat la première solution serait
d'abord de prendre une décision c'est à
dire en gros c'est alterne face et ces
deux solutions différentes entre la
mairie de paris qui fait du social
et le et la région qui veut faire un
petit peu plus du coercitif et c est
prendre en charge de force ces gens là
il faut qu'à un moment donné il se met
avec l'état autour de la table et qui
est une solution qui soit prise un petit
peu radicale puisque là ça fait quand
même des dizaines d'années qu'on voit ce
problème du crack évoluer dans la
capitale et que on gère on gère
l'existant gère le quotidien la police
la préfecture de police soit là en cas
de la chose comme un peu mais donc on ne
prend pas le problème
on déplace le problème au gré des
scandales politiques etc cette date
n'avait pas tort puisque effectivement
les élus de pantin pouvait se douter
qu'ils avaient quelque chose s'y
préparer puisque la la place auguste
baron qui a été sélectionné avait déjà
été évoquée en juin donc c est là l
abattoir là dessus et après donc là
l'autre solution c'est effectivement
donc de lutter sur la prise en charge
des toxicomanes et encore une fois je
reparle de ces dealers de ces mots doux
et c'est d'essayer quand même c'est pas
une drogue légale il faut il ya des lois
et maintenant il ya des moyens d'action
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre pour régler
le problème de tous ces délinquants qui
dealent
merci luc-antoine je crois que vous
allez devoir nous quitter en tout cas je
vous dis au revoir et merci pour vous
explique l'ons en tout cas nous on va
continuer à suivre cette manifestation
avec notre autre journaliste qui est sur
place tivo ysore merci luc-antoine on
retrouve donc tous vos papiers sur
lefigaro.fr dans les pages du figaro
donc vous êtes en charge des faits
divers au figaro à bientôt pour un autre
direct merci où on va retourner tout de
suite sur le terrain voir les images de
thibaut ysore
et on est entre
action faire prendre ses responsabilités
à l'état
je vous remercie nous avez rappelé 607,5
millions de trajets si à vendre et la
galette trois sphères des couleurs le
dha voisine
alors je vais passer l'accord l'a24
livre est né
un
réseau diffusant des gardiens du
chanteur n'a pas pu venir
parce qu'il ya du monde
à
chaque fois aux
habitants
et alémaniques d'accord a tranché
surtout sauver leur vie pour venir taper
la colère de monsieur
problème dans ce secteur et chansons
d'injection des stages et voilà
comment la brigade
de plus en plus il appelle un grand
tour je vais pas pouvoir qui préserve
tout voyage non et je vais sortir le
soir ya trois joueurs du jour toutes les
non plus quand vettel avait des cracks
instaurons cb moi j'ai pas les moyens
pour les déplacements dans les quartiers
bobos pourquoi pas dans le cinquième
pourquoi pas dans le mondial de la
saison
camille lacourt
en cour des miracles la route c'est là
qu'on tende la main tendue de ce fait ne
lui en train de s'organiser en
associations encombrement de collectifs
aussi bien avec les parisiens que les
albertivillariens hellip anti noir on
envisage de monter une structure
associative au pouvoir faire des recours
juridiques contre l'état pour mise en
danger d'autrui on fait ce qu'on peut on
je suis citoyenne comme moi où j'ai vécu
des situations compliquées comme vous et
c'est enfin vraiment vraiment insisté
sur le fait qu' on est là pour défendre
la cause de chacun de sacs souverain
wahhabite le quartier je travaille dans
ce quartier on est toutes libres 1 pour
ma part exacte rue solférino à des leurs
fenech est juste à côté loin il ajoute
rue des cités on est vraiment enclavé
dans ce secteur regroupe trop de haut de
niveau de difficulté pardon et en tant
que femme de surcroît j'ai parlé pour
nadia une excuse moi mais en tant que
femme c'est déjà difficile de faire
entendre notre parole je suis fils de
s'imposer et donc c'est pour ça que je
le leur ou des porte parole possible
pour faire l'état parole des femmes au
sein de ces quartiers que zone 80
oui on a vachement apporte toujours un
peu pris vis à vis du
gym d'autres car cela n'avait gagné
je vais m'écarter pour recontextualiser
un petit peu ce qui se passe si jamais
vous nous rejoignez sur figaro règles
pour ce rassemblement avantage me carte
un petit peu avant de revenir là bas
pour vous faire suivre un petit peu
cette scène d'une force assez rare en
tout cas moi qui ai l'habitude des
mobilisations sociales et les
rassemblements ou également des
rassemblements de vie locale ici et bien
beaucoup de forces dans ses échanges
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'incompréhension
beaucoup de colère un grand ras-le-bol
exprimés par certains habitants qui se
plaignent finalement de la pauvreté et
les difficultés de leurs 2 lors de leur
localité de leur commune de leur
quartier avec et bien vous l'avez
entendu beaucoup d'altercations entre
certaines personnes qui se plaignent
finalement est bien de l'aspect tardif
de l'intervention médiatique est
également des déclarations des élus face
à une situation qui pour ces personnes
ne sont pas nouvelles avec beaucoup de
pauvreté mais également beaucoup de
problèmes liés à certains faits
criminels et du coup et bien beaucoup
beaucoup de ras-le-bol dans ce
rassemblement derrière nous avec d'un
côté bien les élus qui se sont un peu
mis son côté face à beaucoup beaucoup
vient de ras-le-bol face à leurs
déclarations et de l'autre côté beaucoup
de riverains qui exprime et bien leur
quotidien face à cette situation qui
finalement ne comprend pas que le
déplacement de personnes toxicomanes
constitué entre paris et papilles des
pantins alors je demande à toucher sur
le thème présent
faire pression cette région sur le
préfet de paris et surtout sur monsieur
darmanin qui n'atteindront même
religieux
merci beaucoup
bonsoir à tous je suis en basse altitude
je fais un point que même les policiers
les fois par mois
elle est pas sous les ordres et les
passionnés zone elle est sous les eaux
encore un show d'une préfecture hills je
vais essayer plutôt sur le voyeur vous
attendez pas à des miracles mais elle
veut dire que quand ça va tu rentres
loire ils interviennent quand même
[Musique]
officiellement bâtiment
j'ai c'est que les gars sont assez dures
mais là c'est la craie d'indicés
le sodium mais ça
n'a pas suffi
non
il veut
oui
et
j'ai moi même
eh bien
donc voilà donc que c'est pour vous dire
que nous sommes là un est tout sauf ça
[Applaudissements]
j'habite un dernier
coup l'équipe à la plage
et s'il est de rester calme s'il vous
plaît
on est là pour la volt aussi pour tout
le monde
juste à jouer juste
le problème était déjà bien important
avant le profil semble aussi de plus en
plus j'habite sur la dette de la ville
est justement ce matin à 1 heure du
matin je faisais même plus sortir pour
me cacher
il en avait quatre sans compter dans les
parkings
sait très bien que tous les mercredis
quand on se rassemble en un complice
tous dialoguer brooklyn son bataillon on
est tous pareils que soient les avertit
ville à rien ou les patinoires où l'état
rien on est tous dans le même
merci
les beaux discours ses banques en fait
si l'on passe quelque chose et là ils
analyseront aux personnes en a rien à
[ __ ] ici on gêne personne donc on vous
propose si vous êtes d'accord et du
coulin ses nombreux ça devrait se passer
tranquillement son problème de sécurité
on va monter sur le périphérique où l'on
suivait merci
[Musique]
le dernier disque de vienne
un intérêt
qui maya décennies vous m'entendez y
avait un risque il faut déplacer je
crois pas le micro pour faire joli je
m'en tape du micro écoutez blaise que
j'avoue dur toutes les personnes qui
voudraient faire la moindre violence
contre les craqueur et les troquer sa
très mode et le gouvernement je peux
pour les personnes soient claires il ya
une manière d'exprimer sa colère le
musée de l'auto entreprise habilitée
enfin entendu il n'ya de mer attendue ya
des élus qui ont entendu ya la police
qui a entendu il ya des journalistes qui
ont envie qu'ils ont hâte à vue elles
ont un peu de passion dans votre
souffrance dans notre colère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
invités
une partie de la perte des personnes qui
étaient rassemblés ici
à porte de pantin et bien a choisi de
changer un peu de modes d'action pour se
faire entendre j'avais notamment des
élus et des journalistes qui sont
présents ce soir ils ont décidé bien
nous diriger vers le périphérique alors
que la circulation est encore
extrêmement dense à cette heure de la
journée et des retours du travail
avec vous le voyez bien
les images importante et forte qui ne
concerne pas une grande partie de la
population avec seulement quelques
dizaines de manifestants mais a
toutefois et bien un shack puisqu'on
peut voir
bien le périphérique se rapprocher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui vient d'être bloqués ici du côté
part de pantin
[Musique]
oui
et donc vous le voyez la circulation qui
est bloqué face à cette
cette colère des habitants
[Musique]
alors
vous n'avez entendez tout à l'heure un
plusieurs messages
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs messages de colère
exprimée par les soit si cette colère
qui se représente directement
symboliquement si les autorités ont
elles dressé un mur pour séparer bien
accès qui relie les villes de pantin à
celle de paris
eh bien les habitants de rassembleur
sur le périphérique est bien
chargé en plus leur ras-le-bol 6 pas
exprimé sur les routes a par exemple
[Musique]
alors que là les forces de police
arrivent loppement
[Musique]
il se doit
et donc en premier officier vient
échanger avec certains manifestants
alors que vous voyez les voitures
derrière continue de
ralentir la circulation qui se bloquent
progressivement
on va se rapprocher de ses discussions
avec les forces de police
comment
[Musique]
ils sont où les élus
ici c'est pour l'étude des années les
élus
parmi ces populations concernées
ces déplacements de personnes
eh bien vous priver le voir derrière
cette personne qui sont présentant comme
un symbole avec bien des tentes qui sont
qui sont dépliés le long le long du
gazon et sur cette ut sur cet accès au
périphérique désormais même bloqué par
la police pour éviter des deux trop gros
ralentissements mais bien cette
population qui exprime son ras-le-bol on
en a marre
[Musique]
cette banderole un
genévrier
[Musique]
tout faux
la guerre des images extrêmement fort
que ce soir vous l'avez entendu après
une première partie qu'on a pu suivre en
direct avec des déclarations d'élus est
une sorte de tribune médiatique pourra
exprimer bien les problèmes de cette
zone est finalement un coup de gueule
très fort d'un coup qui est venu un peu
haché rouge figure à pourrait bien l
inverse expliqué de la part de certains
est vrai que les problèmes sont produits
hier très bien il ya également des
problèmes d'insécurité depuis de
nombreuses années et que les relations
avec la police est toujours là dans
l'ordre des choses pour et bien faire
sentir
rien être sécurité au quotidien mais
donc et bien au delà d'une simple
question déplacements de populations aux
toxicomanes
bien là on est clairement dans une
expression beaucoup plus ancrée dans la
vie locale de la ville de pantin mais
également de la zone avec et bien pas
loin aubervilliers et de l'autre côté le
19e arrondissement de paris
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc vous l'avez vu donc cette
action menée donc sur les images en
direct de thibaut is aurait donc le
rassemblement quelques manifestants qui
se sont déplacés pour boucher l'une des
voies d'entrée sur le périphérique
parisien
les forces de l'ordre qui ont donc
invité ces manifestants à partir donc on
le voit sur ces sur ces images en direct
de notre reporter figaro live thibault
il aurait donc les manifestants
retournent alors point de rassemblement
initial je vous rappelle que nous sommes
en direct depuis maintenant une heure
sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre page
youtube pour couvrir ce rassemblement ce
jour de mobilisation
des habitants de pantin d'aubervilliers
et de porte de la villette on va écouter
cette ce témoignage en direct tout de
suite
où la paire pour les enfants on ne peut
pas l'avenir de nos enfants
beaubois ne l'aimé pas de paris 6ème
vous parie que
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors que certains conducteurs
excédé sortent de leur véhicule cette
sortie désormais du périphérique
parisien qui est bloqué l'averse de
l'entrée tout à l'heure donc certes un
certain certains automobilistes qui
sortent de leur véhicule on va essayer
d'aller voir ça de loin sans trop
s'avancer pour rester au coeur de la
mobilisation mais vous pouvez voir voilà
les personnes qui sortent de leur
véhicule assez assez surprise de la
scène à laquelle il assiste
[Musique]
donc quelques automobilistes qui font la
queue parce qu'ils sont bloqués donc par
quelques manifestants excédés qui
protestent contre l'installation on va
dire le déplacement des toxicomane accro
au crack qui ont été déplacées du 18ème
et 19ème arrondissements de paris vers
pantin et aubervilliers à la porte de la
villette c'est un rassemblement qui dure
depuis maintenant plus d'une heure vingt
et que vous suivez avec nous en direct
depuis une heure vous voyez ces
manifestants dont qui ceux qui
s'assoient
à une sortie du périph en tout cas dans
le chat vous êtes nombreux je vais je
vais vous saluer vous êtes nombreux à
parler il ya beaucoup de travail de
modération visiblement tout cas sur
notre chat youtube beaucoup de messages
sont supprimés par notre équipe des
réseaux sociaux parce que ce que vous
dites ne correspond pas à notre charte
de déontologie donc beaucoup de messages
supprimés en tout cas je salue ludovic
cheville et et m au commodore et they
have elle vaut ce cas veljko ce cas
pardon qui déclare donc sur le chat le
chat youtube je crains quand je crains
bien qu'en france pardon je crains bien
qu'en france des mauvaises choses vont
se passer trop de pression ce n'est pas
bien ils ont raison apparemment ils
partent manifester sur le périph et hd
de tonton 2 qui nous demandait il ya
maintenant plusieurs minutes qu'est ce
qui se passe la même chose pour kris
kross donc sur le chat du figaro.fr
cette fois ci qui nous demandaient
qu'est ce qui se passe voilà notre
journaliste thibault ysore nous l'a bien
expliqué en direct une partie des
manifestants que nous suivions et qu'il
était donc porte de pantin a rassemblé
au initialement devant le mur qui a été
érigé pour de la villette bush
actuellement une sortie de périph
alors tu ne
vois là les habitants j ai décidé de
fabriquer alors que l'on voyait derrière
le trafic est bien sans magasiner en
direction du périphérique à la tête et
bien cette cette auto moto neige
extrêmement énervé excédés et 7 cette
riveraine qui explique bien non bougera
pas on veut se faire entendre avec cette
impression de silence on a pu et bien
entendre régulièrement autour de la
situation est bien de la ville est en
tout cas de ce quartier des quatre
chemins avec certaines affichent une
affiche que j'ai pouvoir avec un fantôme
expliquant vraiment qu'on ne parle pas
finalement de la situation quotidienne
ces hommes ces femmes plusieurs peuvent
exprimer
dans un cycle
quotidienne qu'elle peut être connaître
mes enfants qui viendraient bien
parents et qu'ils ont cadenassé par
contre ces populations un peu dangereux
tu peux venir et qu'ils sont et bien
condamné
décidément cet automobiliste
vraiment pas très content je suis au
milieu du trafic on va essayer de faire
attention
et donc voilà vous le voyez en tout cas
si les images sont extrêmement fortes
cela ne concerne finalement qu'une
poignée de manifestants doux et bien et
ont cessé de la chance pour les
automobilistes mais dont finalement la
relative fragilité du barrage qui a été
installé donc les véhicules qui
reprennent très très très tranquillement
leur route en direction est bien de la
sortie de paris et en direction pantin
ici à porte de pantin à la sortie du
périphérique ball
wii alors j'ai quelqu'un dans le chat
qui claudius 15 qui nous dit de fin qui
me dit de vous dire faites attention à
vous effectivement parce que vous êtes
quand même au beau milieu du trafic et
j'ai une autre question cette fois-ci de
ludovic janvier qui demande où sont les
forces de l'ordre il ya personne qui en
garde qui encadre cette manifestation
c'est ce sont c'est une très bonne
question en effet bruno déjà merci pour
vos messages de soutien heureusement on
n'a pas pris trop de risques et sur
toute personne dans la prix heureusement
voilà ce rassemblement soudan un peu
peur pro visé se fait en tout cas dans
une relative sûreté mais en effet pas de
présence des forces de l'ordre qui sont
de l'autre côté on apporte de pantin et
du côté parisien deux points derrière
moi on se trouvait il ya quelques
minutes ou en fait bien les forces de
l'ordre là nous ont accompagnés ont
commencé à bloquer la structure et la
circulation pour la lui permettent de
continuer son chemin et de faire un duo
finalement et de passants magazines et
sur le périphérique qui a été bloqué par
par la foule donc là la population des
forces de l'ordre qui elle est bien ne
nous a pas suivis ici à la sortie du
père y est donc et bien pas
d'encadrement ligne au niveau de la
sécurité au niveau de la régulation de
de ce rassemblement là qui n'est pas
déclaré que malheureusement pas
autorisés est donc bien c'est vrai que
c'est surprenant on est aussi bien les
habits d'une population de riverains et
non vient de manifestants qui ont
l'habitude d'être encadrés par les
forces de l'ordre en moi j'ai l'habitude
de sublimes jeunes elana à la poly la
présence de la police et quasiment
systématique
et bien ici non la
libre entre guillemets sans présence
d'encadrement et c'est peut-être aussi
ça que les riverains condamne dans les
messages que j'ai pu entendre depuis
tout à l'heure c'est notamment cette
absence de la police où l'absence de
réponse de la police vis-à-vis d'une
situation et qui excède very bras face à
une insécurité qui n'est pas
je continue de lire par jh je continue
de lire vos commentaires sur sur le cha
du figaro et criss cross du cou qui
continue de paris dans le chat géant
remercier qui nous qui donne son message
de soutien à tous les pans tinois
soutien à tous les continents qui
doivent supporter l'arrivée de 2 to say
toxico le 9-3 n'est pas une poubelle et
christian léon toussaint qui continuent
dans la lancée et qui dit l'état n'a pas
vocation à nettoyer toutes les rues
voilà en revanche claude juste 15 et pas
et pas forcément d'accord avec cette
action entreprise sur le périph alors
que l'on voit du coup sûr les images ça
y est la police vient vient d'arriver
c'était une question qui nous est posée
dans le tchat
la police vient donc d'arriver peut-être
pour déplacer ces manifestants et
surtout libéré le périph
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o o
un
procureur
ce dont parle de la situation c'est
assez surprenant d'ailleurs puisque
finalement la situation tend même à
devenir dangereuse puisque certains
automobilistes excédés essaie de forcer
le passage du chemin on espère que ça va
pas finir de façon dramatique mais en
tout cas vous le voyez une situation
extrêmement étrange avec ses forces de
police qui se tiennent à quelques mètres
de la situation ici de blocage du
périphérique et qui vient interviennent
pas là il imagine bien que vu bien là la
dimension compliquer la situation ça va
être difficile d'intervenir comme cela
mais ce serait en tout cas intéressant
de voir ce qui va pouvoir se passer
pendant les prochaines minutes
[Musique]
dirigés dans l'autre sens en autre point
de blocage du périphérique parisien on
va essayer d'aller à la recherche
d'autres d'autres témoignages pour
essayer de coupe est un peu là on a déjà
parlé à deux trois personnes de ce
groupe là alors que wayere défense de
police qui sont toujours immobile qui se
tiennent sans agir à quelques mètres
d'ici et de l'autre côté finalement bien
c'est la circulation qui a pu reprendre
malgré la présence quand même de
certains manifestants semble-t-il et
surtout une présence policière
importante pour empêcher le trafic est
bien d'intervenir et de pouvoir se
glisser en direction de la zone bloqués
par les manifestants est donc bien voilà
en tout cas les forces de police sauf
qu'ils sont là pour en tout cas bien
faire tourner la circulation
retournée comme un niveau du blocage si
on a déjà parlé à 3 de personnes et ce
sera peut-être plus
plus fort à suivre ici j'ai même du mal
à identifier les personnes qui
manifestent et les personnes qui sont en
dépassant les passantes
les referees paris périphérique parisien
qui est l'objet bel et bien notamment
symbolique de cette situation ce soir
puisque c'est sous ce périphérique qui a
été construit un mur pour empêcher
l'accès aux personnes en situation
taximen toxicomanie ont été déplacées du
jardin d'eole hainaut stalingrad et bien
d'accéder au delà l'extérieur de paris
et de pouvoir sortir ou en tout cas et
bien errer dans les rues de pantin par
exemple ça aussi bien c'est un symbole
très fort ce mur puisque il ya en
général un pan de la culture et
l'histoire internationale et mais on
n'est jamais bon signe et surtout et
bien c'est aussi un symbole de
l'inaction pour les pour les riverains
de la part des autorités tant nationales
que locales c'est à dire eh bien comme
pour les cités a fait selon eux de
déplacer la situation en déplaçant
parlement les toxicomanes alors
empêchant l'accès à savoir
patiemment mais pas trop
bras
voilà le premier contact avec les forces
de police qui viennent qui viennent
demander aux manifestants de s'écarter
de la route et vous lassiez toxiques ou
nevers et comptera plus que là bas on
dégage et on laisse les toxicos m
ses cousins ils vont faire un grand
supermarché de la drogue ici et une 19e
sinon un programme est
exprimée notamment messieurs la firme
soit je veux qu a fait l'aller-retour
policiers qui notamment de retourner sur
le trottoir alors que certains riverains
bien discuté avec la police mais oublié
que c'était la raison de leur album ce
soir et de leurs actions ici aux portes
du périphérique parisien
voilà
pourquoi vraiment
les policiers ont cependant votre
sécurité aussi on se bat pour votre
sécurité qu'en fait attaquer avec
des pointes de seraing
on
s'était bien étriqué
je comprends pas ou plus les
revenants mais là on est
allé
en fait on nous en promet de voir si je
suis moins que la bouche est un produit
légal
mais
benoît gilles
kern qui tout compte fait quatre mois on
le savait qu'est ce qu'il a
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coup sûr tenue fashion en heure
c'est encore les libraires alors qu'on
se bat pour la sécurité aussi des
policiers
vous êtes les premiers à être victime de
ça on se bat pour vous s'il vous avez de
merde
[Musique]
c'est l'endroit le plus dangereux vous
allez faire quoi quand vous allez
intervenir et qui vont vous balance et
écouter et vous avait déjà parlé de ça
allez vous ne vous avez bien pas ses
divisions et des légumes quand même
étonné c'est quoi nous tenons également
à la nourriture feu abattant voulons
mais pleine balade
rien branler depuis très longtemps quand
je vois caire qui prend le micro qui
parle qui ne laisse même pas la parole
aux vibrations dire mieux alors nous
allons faire des réunions euro valant
établir un calendrier de réunions
jusqu'à 2025 alors que ces mêmes mêmes
gens là ils refusent des subventions à
des associations qui font de la
prévention et qui s'occupe d'insertion
et qui encadre des jeunes ils refusent
des logements ils les aident pas il
développe la précarité ces gens là
parlent hélas aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on a on a encore en rester là
[Musique]
encore une fois
encore
mais bien sûr c'est nous les gens tiff
on se revoit nous on se reparle la grèce
personne on n'agresse personne et sait
nous des fois qu'ils devront faire la
police basque a pas assez de policiers
et on aime la police on vous aime on
vous aime ont aussi passé on vous aime
on vous aime on a besoin de vous mais
soyez avec nous soyez avec nous
dégager les mettez les dans un centre
fermé qui ce cheval il ya des criminels
il ya des violeurs il ya des assassins
d'ailleurs monsieur bien démarrer mon
fils là bas il ya des pédophiles
on s'en fout selon
l'aclu sont bas les couilles on lâchera
rien tu parles avec qui
non non ils sont pas qui coûte de notre
spa pour tous mais ils nous ont dit
d'appeler le 17 est la magnifique balcon
tout le monde
porter plainte j'ai pas dit ça en fait
ce que j'ai dit en gros amateur elle
porte le maire dit alors il a parlé si
on parle en plus en mai à temps mais
j'espère
d'achat
ferries et mon frère tu étais mon team
du temple est utile d'appeler les
candidats les portes blanches tt le
mérite a dit appeler les conflits le
maire il a pas tout le pouvoir fait
préfet le district la place de l'argent
qu'est-ce que vous la verrez c'est sûr
que ce n'est pas parce qu'il veut
si vous voulez les monsieur loyal
voilà bah oui vous avez dit agir
pacifiquement wynn las et choisit les
pacifiquement oui bah maintenant on va
utiliser le 3 son nom n'est certes pas
le tout entre parce qu'après tout rejet
de tout chez moi mais est ce que c'est
bon d'avoir des voisins toxicomane
violent ou si tout le monde sait des
pédophiles et des violeurs hisser en
tête quand il tend comme tu verras quand
les gens vous quand tu me prends pas
choquant je comprends que les gens comme
moi je suis bien
comporté
et l'avortement out alors leur
comportement a eu
[Musique]
là il mourra de combien de clients
sérieux
voilà on va se retirer on va
certainement rendre l'antenne je vais
bien sûr rester ici à pantin pour suivre
l'évolution de cette situation la fois
intéressante j'ai même envie de dire une
des situations les plus fortes
auxquelles j'ai pu assister dans ma la
très jeune carrière il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de symboles on a
commencé au pied du mur qui sépare
pantin de la capitale en burki a été
construit récemment par les autorités
pour justement empêcher les populations
toxicomanes déplacer devenir niveau de
pantin et ce mur symbolique utilisée
comme point de départ d'un second
rassemblement puisque le premier a eu
lieu la semaine dernière et bien ce mur
est bien ce rassemblement pardon qui
débutait comme une tribune politique un
appel des élus locaux aux journalistes
qu'aux finalement à la france entière et
au gouvernement qu'il a pour le coup est
principalement mis en cause c'est
surtout d'arman qui a été critiqué ce
soir est bien un appel de la part de ses
élus deux conseillers municipaux
également ajustements vient faire
quelque chose pour la situation ici est
finalement ces déclarations et bien ont
été interrompues par les riverains
eux-mêmes alors aucune violence a en
tout cas a déclaré ce soir mais beaucoup
beaucoup d'altercations verval non
agression mais bien sûr avec beaucoup
beaucoup de
d'énervement beaucoup de colère de la
part d'hommes de femmes de tous âges ans
c'est ça qui est intéressant à suivre a
précisé fasse finalement une heure
sécurité qui n'est pas nouvelle et c'est
bien ce qu'on dit c'est rivera en tout
cas une insécurité qui existe depuis
plusieurs années bien depuis bien
longtemps pour cette zone au fort taux
de criminalité et qui donc est bien
aujourd'hui se représente vis-à-vis de
cette situation des toxicomanes ensuite
eh bien vous l'avez vu cette population
qui a décidé de quitter rassemblement
pour aller bloquer le père y est
désormais bien on se retrouve avec les
policiers que ces riverains
s'entretiennent pour justement exprimé
leur colère mais aussi et bien pouvoir
partager avec ces hommes et ces femmes
de l'ordre qui au quotidien et bien
interviennent dans la zone b qui sont
bien eux aussi concernés par ce
déplacement des toxicomanes
si merci thibault pour tous ce moment
vécu en direct sur figaro live avec
beaucoup de gens du coup dans le chat je
les salue juan talibés sont co rie
touche free touch qui dit bravo il y en
a marre bravo les habitants soutien aux
habitants du quartier et patrick huile
qui dit bravo à ceux qui parlent
effectivement on a entendu beaucoup de
gens parlaient beaucoup de gens
s'invectiver comme le rappelait à
l'instant thibault ysore des gens qu'on
n'entend pas forcément souvent en direct
en tout cas voilà je salue également nos
habitués du chat sur lefigaro.fr
christian léon toussaint kriss kross et
jean paul ii qui nous qui vient nous
rejoindre c'est l'impression dans le
tchat nous allons donc terminer ce set
cette séquence cette manifestation que
nous avons vu en direct jambes je
remercie julien qu'une aile à la
réalisation nous vous retrouvons et
pardon luc-antoine le noir que vous avez
vu tout à l'heure qui est parti à 19
heures je le remercie également qui a
porté ses éclairages sur cette situation
qui ne date en fin qui date qui n'est
pas nouvelle et qui maintenant s'est
déplacé vers la porte de la villette et
pantin et aubervilliers donc
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
sur figaro life pour un autre direct et
je vous quitte avec ses images de
thibaut iso recchi qui restent encore
sur place et qui continuera de couvrir
l'événement pour le figaro.fr votre
soirée
parma